les fantômes existent je les ai vus
toute ma vie les fantômes
j'étais loin d'imaginer quel était votre
source d'inspiration c'est pas mal du
tout je te dire vraiment
l'inde où je viens on ne prend pas les
fantômes ain el cheikh je comprends
votre fascination pour la famille sharp
et dit je vous présente ma soeur mais
soyez extrêmement prudente
j'ai le sentiment
quel lien invisible unis votre coeur est
le mien
comment faites vous pour vous occuper de
ce manoir c'est un vrai village dit être
né un de ceux auxquels on ne peut
renoncer
pourriez vous me donner un double des
clés s'il vous plaît ce n'est pas utile
certaines parties de la maison sont
dangereuses
dans ses murs délabrés dans l'obscurité
des secrets sont partout
thomas quelqu'un est il mort dans ce
lieu est debout avec moi faites-moi
d'une mort étrange
d'une mort violente
une demeure aussi ancien fini avec le
temps par prendre vie
elle commence par s'attacher aux choses
certaines bénéfique
d'autres néfaste est certaine que l'on
devrait être à jamais
que voulez vous